Margaret Brennan is at the white house
where former President Obama is Charlie
mentioned at the top of the show Worst
Warren then president elect Trump about
general Flynn Margaret good morning good
morning while mr. Obama cautioned then
president-elect Trump against hiring
Flynn
this was advice given before the scandal
had erupted regarding misleading
statements made by Flynn to the vice
president about his contact with the
Russian ambassador we now are going to
want to do everything we can to help you
succeed during a 90 minute conversation
two days after the election President
Obama shared some personnel advice with
the man who would replace him very much
according to former officials familiar
with their conversation mr. Obama told
the president-elect he should go with
his instincts and hire people he wanted
with one exception retired General
Michael Flynn mr. Obama cautioned that
the new president would be wise to stay
away Trump aides say he was suspicious
of mr. Obama's motives in coming forward
American exceptionalism is very real
Flynn had regularly criticized
administration policy during the
campaign mr. Obama had fired him as head
of the Defense Intelligence Agency
citing an abrasive management style
among other issues it's true that
President Obama made it known that he
wasn't exactly a fan of general Flynn's
White House press secretary Sean Spicer
said it wasn't surprising the former
president didn't like general Flynn
given their past history Spicer then
shifted the blame to the Obama
administration noting that they had
renewed Flynn's security clearance in
April of last year the question that you
have to ask yourself really is if
President Obama was truly concerned
about general Flynn why didn't he
suspend general Flynn's security
clearance which they had just read surly
err but it's the defense intelligence
agency not the White House that would
have revoked Flynn's clearance it had
been renewed in 2016 before it came to
light that Flynn had failed to report
compensation related to Russia and it
was hold right after President Trump
dismissed him
running at the White House thanks
Margaret